DOESN'T GO.
HARRIS TURNS THE CORNER.
DAVIS EXTENDS OUT.
STICKS ANOTHER.
TWO BIG BUCKETS HERE FOR TOBIAS
HARRIS.
94-78.
CARMELO ANTHONY WILL GET INTO IT
WITH SOME FANS HERE.
JUST BEHIND OUR BROADCAST AREA.
THEY'VE BEEN RIDING HIM FOR
ABOUT FOUR STRAIGHT POSSESSIONS.
MELO STARTED LOOKING IN THEIR
DIRECTION.
NOW MELO HAS HAD ENOUGH AND GAB
TO MOVE TOWARD THEM.
LEON STEPPED IN WITH SECURITY.
AND THERE MIGHT BE AN EJECTION
IN PLAY HERE.
>> THE REFEREES.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF GUYS.
I THINK THEY'LL GET THROWN OUT.
I THOUGHT CARMELO WAS GOING
OVER.
I SAW HIM COMING OVER HERE.
I SAID WHAT IS IT THAT HE SAID?
THAT COULD HAVE SO UPSET CARMELO
ANTHONY?
>> IT WAS JUST MY GENERAL PLAY
BY PLAY, APPARENTLY.
THIS FORTUNATELY DID NOT GO
BEYOND WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
THERE WAS A MOMENT WHERE ANTHONY
CONTINUED TO CHARGE.
AND KEVIN CUTLER GOT IN THERE.
AND SECURITY THEN SWARMED INTO
THE AREA TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DID NOT EXACERBATE LEON WOOD
POINTED TO THE FANS, AND THEY
HAVE BEEN ESCORTED TO THE TUNNEL
AREA.
NOW THE QUESTION, WILL THEY BE
ESCORTED OUT?
>> YEAH.
THEY'RE GONE.
A GREAT JOB BY